Elon Musk is threatening to sue the
Anti-Defamation League
for defamation
I love this story so much
been meaning to get to it for a few days
now it's just it's just been simmering
and it gets better and better and better
the Anti-Defamation League
is a group ostensibly founded to stop
anti
semitism to stop hatred against the
Jewish people and smears against the
Jewish people that's not really what it
does I mean I guess that's part of what
it does but the Anti-Defamation League
will happily attack fellow Jews if those
Jews happen to be conservative or happen
to question the liberal narrative so the
Anti-Defamation League will happily
attack Libs of tick tock an Orthodox
Jewish woman because she doesn't toe the
party line and the Anti-Defamation
League will talk about things that have
nothing to do with the Jews whatsoever
just plain regular old left-wing
nonsense and the way that they do it is
by bandying around this accusation of
anti-Semitism just a specific version of
the race card which is the biggest card
you can play in America it's the worst
thing you can possibly be called and
they say hey if you oppose Hillary
Clinton you're an anti-semite hey if you
don't like Joe Biden you're an
anti-semite hey if you don't allow us to
censor your your platform we're going to
call you an anti-semite in fact the the
Anti-Defamation League has sent out
threats this is documented we have
letters threats to I think this there
was one that they sent to Iceland uh but
they've done this a number of times
where they will say hey I bet you sure
wouldn't like it if we called you a Nazi
whether or not the accusation is fair so
you better toe the line they'll threaten
to lie about people so there was a
really awful organization and Elon Musk
came out
he himself having been defamed by the
ADL and said to clear our platform's
name on the matter of anti-Semitism it
looks like we have no choice but to file
a defamation lawsuit against the
Anti-Defamation League oh the irony
love it so absolutely go after the ADL
you should go after some of the other
groups too though it's not just the ADL
it's groups like right wing watch which
is a project of people for the American
way which is a one of the most
ironically named groups in America
because it is a handful of Elites for a
very Un-American way there are several
others out there where these groups
exist they're watching the show right
now and they try to clip out little
pieces of the show and get us all fired
and they try to censor people on on
social media my only
request as we take down all of these
left-wing sensor groups and we actually
wield political power because there's no
such thing as a neutral Public Square
there's no such thing as a neutral
political order we're going to have to
stand for something or other we're going
to have to push certain people out to
the fringes and I absolutely think we've
got to push these liberal sensors out to
the fringes my one request to Elon
though is as we take them all down
please don't take down my publicists at
Media Matters I have had a very good
working relationship with Media Matters
for many years now
they watch my show every day they're
watching it now they clip out some of
the best parts of my show and then I get
to retweet them and they get a lot more
eyeballs on my work so please
my take down the ADL take down right
wing watch do whatever you want but
please I have no interest in finding a
new set of publicists
now I also have no interest in going out
and replacing my propane tank which is
why it's such a great thing that we've
got cinch right now head on over to
cinch.com use code Knowles have you ever
craved a nice juicy barbecue meal with
the family so you go to the store get
all the groceries you invite the family
over or it's gonna be a fun time right
but then
you go to turn on the grill
and you're a propane tank is completely
empty well that's where cinch comes in
to save the day cinch is a propane grill
tank Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule and
requires no long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home you track the order on
the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're grilling steaks or lighting up
the patio heaters on a cold night
cinches propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment go online to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code Knowles Canada WLS that's
cinch.com or download the Cinch app use
promo code Knowles to get your first
tank exchange for just 10 bucks it's a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it go
to cinch.com offer for details so
Elon opens himself up by threatening to
sue the Anti-Defamation League
guess how the ADL responds you know how
the IDL is going to respond and the head
of the ADL Jonathan Greenblatt they're
going to say that any attempt to stop
them from censoring the American public
square is drum roll anti-semitism
were you seeking to have some kind of
either role at Twitter or any kind of
donations made or other things no I only
say that because there have been folks
who've looked at these situations and
felt that they were being you know
shaken down
look I think let me be honest about that
right I think it is sort of anti-Semitic
Trope to suggest when Jewish people
Express a degree of outrage over
anti-Semitism that somehow that's a
Shakedown because Jews are greedy
so the answer to the question is
obviously yes obviously Greenblatt and
the ADL
were seeking a role in censoring Twitter
the way that we know that Elon Musk
showed this is that ADL started its
boycott of Twitter ADL is largely
responsible for the drop in Twitter
Revenue after Elon Musk took over and we
know that the ADL launched its
anti-twitter campaign the moment that
Elon took over so the moment Elon takes
over nothing changes in the service of
Twitter over time he's implemented some
changes but nothing changes the moment
that he takes over but
in the ADL starts the
the Shakedown the ADL starts the
harassment campaign in order to do what
to just have fun on a Saturday afternoon
no in order to get a seat at the table
and have a role in shaping the content
of Twitter
and he says he's doing it in the name of
of stopping anti-Semitism or whatever
but that's obviously not I want to be as
charitable as possible maybe that's a
part of the adl's mission I'm somewhat
skeptical but certainly
the the mission is not merely that how
could you argue that trying to shut up
one of the most prominent Orthodox
Jewish women in the entire country is is
a good way to stop anti-Semitism it
would seem to be maybe an example of
anti-Semitism a self-hating sort of
anti-summit anti-anti-semitic campaign
I'm getting lost in the Inception of it
all
yeah that's what it is and so what does
he do when he gets caught his eyes open
wide he's oh no I didn't you're an
anti-semite for even asking that and and
this is of course the case accusations
of racism are always so
cheap they're so cheap including the
specific case of accusations of
anti-Semitism but but anything
anti-black anti-hispanic anti this anti
that other than anti-white you're not
allowed to even suggest that Prospect in
our culture the only group that you're
legally and culturally permitted and
encouraged to discriminate against an
insult you're not even allowed to bring
up the prospect of that but for any
other group it comes out and it's always
so cheap I remember
uh David Webb I brought this example up
before David Webb is black conservative
he was on the radio he was interviewing
a black woman who's a liberal and when
he was winning the debate she just said
well that's your white privilege showing
David
because it was radio and she didn't know
what he looked like and he just started
laughing he said uh you know that's not
gonna work on me lady
so what do we do in the face of this in
these cheap accusations of of racism
that are totally disingenuous they're in
bad faith what is our response to that
is our response to care and to beg and
to say no please don't I'm not a racist
to some of my best friends or black
Muslim pygmies or whatever you know
whatever kind of
group is considered the most oppressed
no I don't think so you're not going to
convince them they don't care the
argument is not in good faith then is
the is the alternative to just be really
mean and cruel and discriminatory
against all sorts of different groups to
become what they accuses of it no I
don't think that's the answer either the
answer is
first
stop caring when they call you a racist
or an anti-semite or an anti-dissist or
a phobic or whatever just stop caring
it's not real they don't mean it
they just don't like you and they want
to shut you up so stop caring first of
all but then there is a flip side to
that too which is make sure that you
Orient yourself toward Justice and
charity
those are going to be a lot better
guides than anti-racism or being an ally
against the phobia or a thisism or that
just Orient yourself toward Justice and
charity and pursue the virtues and avoid
the vices and Avail yourself of God's
grace and in in all things act with
Justice and charity and then ignore the
noise who cares about that stuff boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
that you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time